[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
nous
[Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
et
beaucoup
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
on
oh
[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir en passant de la 1ère ps que
vous avez entendu une sonate d domenico
scarlatti à ma pièce offre des skins
il faut se rendre à l'évidence la
musique est universelle que parce
qu'elle est présente dans toutes les
sociétés
ces divers langages sont des codes que
seuls les autochtones d'une culture où
les initiés peuvent comprendre avec
justesse la question culturelle s'étend
jusqu'au code vestimentaire qui
distingue le musicien classique dans la
tennis d'aujourd'hui est issu de dix
neuvième siècle du musicien populaire
qui s'adapte davantage à son temps ce
qui influence notre perception d'un
cancer
mais le choix de la sonate de scarlatti
oeuvres baroques virtuose et de ma pièce
offre des skins oeuvre électroacoustique
illustre aussi que par l'exigence de
leur facture ces oeuvres peuvent
coexister dans un même concert donnant
celui-ci une grande diversité sonore
ça m'amène à vous parler du schéma
proposé au pianiste interprète débutant
une carrière internationale qui est
souvent très circonscrit il faut jouer
du schubert du mozart telles oeuvres de
beethoven ou des chopin ouvre
certes fort intéressante et qui
garantisse la préservation d'une partie
du patrimoine musical européen mais qui
tient peu compte de la diversité des
répertoires pour piano existant dans le
monde amérique aux hits est égal
assurément peu d'entre vous
reconnaîtront ici les musique pour piano
du compositeur cubain comme ernesto
lecuona ayant vécu dans la première
partie du 20ème siècle et dont les
pièces sont un parfait mélange des
rythmes et mélodies issues des musiques
afro-cubaines et espagnol écoute dans un
extrait
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle
le
oooh
[Musique]
à
normal n'est ce pas face à ce constat je
me suis posé une question fondamentale
bien sûr tout en entrant dans le 21e
siècle quel modèle de musiciens voudrais
juste transmettre et serait-il pertinent
de l'appeler classique en ce nouveau
siècle il était clair pour moins que
l'ouverture sur le monde à laquelle
j'aspirais et que je souhaite partager
avec vous avec le public passe par un
décloisonnement total de la figure du
musicien et des notions de classiques
populaires en incluant dans les concerts
aux côtés du répertoire européen du
répertoire latino américains par exemple
en composants dans divers styles deux
expressions musicales en connectant
aussi les réalisations musicales aux
autres arts et en rendant propice la
découverte et la compréhension des
relations existant entre le
développement des arts et le
développement des nouvelles technologies
qui les impacts donc là envie de donner
corps à cette idée m'a conduit à
développer une pratique artistique
pluridisciplinaire appelé la démarche
globale qui permet d'aborder et
l'interprétation et la composition
musicale du point de vue des plusieurs
hasard et dé transmettre cette curiosité
au plus grand nombre possible de
personnes par la synergie que cela
génère entre les différents publics qui
assistent alors une nouvelle voie
est ouverte pour le musicien du 21ème
siècle qui peut réaliser une oeuvre plus
réel en mélangeant les arts en
s'appuyant sur les nouvelles
technologies en libérant une créativité
en dehors des notions de classiques ou
populaires et qui peut s'engager à
transmettre cette envie de connaître ces
relations qui existent entre les publics
dynamiser les relations entre les
générations et créer une beaucoup plus
grande ouverture sur le monde et surtout
instaurer un véritable dialogue allant
de la transmission à l'innovation
[Applaudissements]